Speaker 1: All right.
I want to look at a couple of different things
that my colleague John actually sent me.
Some of you may remember this black MAGA pastor,
Jesse Lee Peterson.
He's been on the program before.
I've been on his show before in Los Angeles,
California.
He recently was involved in, I think it's
fair to call it a scandal where despite leading
a life of public homophobic advocacy about
being gay is bad and immoral and all these
different things, it appears that Jesse Lee
Peterson himself is is gay.
And this exploded in controversy several months
ago.
Somehow, Jesse Lee Peterson ended up on the
Dr. Phil Show.
Now, I'm going to be totally upfront.
I don't think much of the Dr. Phil Show.
And in fact, I had some back and forths with
them about two months ago about having me
on.
They wasted my time.
They were completely disrespectful of my time,
asking me to do a pre-interview and a video
vlog explaining my views, a filling out, providing
answers to dozens of questions.
Then they never even told me, Hey, turns out
we're not going to have you on.
Just never even followed up one of the most
unprofessional outfits I've ever dealt with.
And yet I'm still going to play this for you
with peace and love, because it is so absolutely
fascinating.
Jesse Lee Peterson somehow ended up on the
Dr. Phil Show.
And by the way, this guy on the screen right
now is not Jesse Lee Peterson.
I'm aware of that.
And he just said vile and disgusting things
that actually made an audience member cry.
Let's just jump right into this first clip
that the topic was Is it smart to have children?
Now in the background of all of this with
Jesse Lee Peterson is his personal situation
where he says he's sel?
He told me he was celibate because he's not
married.
And it turns out it's not just that he's not
married to a woman, it's that he's actually
gay and is hiding these relationships.
It's crazy.
Let's just jump right in.
Speaker 2: I disagree with all this crap that
I hear.
I grew up with six brothers and seven sisters
at a time when, you know, I grew up.
Speaker 1: By the way, it's funny that they
identified him as radio host and pastor, which
is like so banal and an anodyne in the context
of how whacked out, completely whacked this
guy is.
Speaker 2: Plantation in Alabama and we grew
up in a nut house bathroom outside.
We my family raised an amazing family, children.
But what they did it was then that it is now
is that before you had babies, you got married,
you have a father and a mother and a home.
And while the fathers are earning a living,
the mother watching over his children.
Speaker 1: And so this entire routine is so
extra hypocritical and ridiculous and absurd,
given what we now know about Jesse Lee Peterson
personally, it's stunning that he still goes
around and says this stuff with a straight
face.
Speaker 2: Able to raise decent children.
We didn't have government in our lives at
the time, and so we were able to do that.
And in America, we were not allowed all these
illegal aliens and refugees to come into our
country.
So our government, we're not taking care of
folks from other parts of the world and families
in America.
We took care of ourselves.
Speaker 4: I think of, oh my God.
Speaker 1: People in the audience visibly
rolling their eyes.
But eventually they cry.
Speaker 4: Pretty much pissed off everybody.
But you said it.
You said there's not anything you've heard
that you don't think is crap.
So what do you think?
And you said what you don't think?
What do you think?
Speaker 2: That we need to restore the family.
We need a smaller government because government
don't make anything work.
Speaker 1: Understand that the family Jesse
Lee Peterson says, must be restored, which
is a man and a woman married.
Having many children is something that he
himself doesn't actually live by because it
appears as though he's a gay man, which is
fine.
But he's spent decades.
AIDS shaming gay men.
It's absolutely disgusting.
And then a little bit later in the show, his
comments actually so vile that they make audience
members who are immigrants break down in tears.
Speaker 4: Do you want to say I.
Speaker 3: Would like to speak to you guys
directly.
You, too.
To your point that poor children are the worst
in the world and that immigrants are also
not a good thing for this country.
I'm someone who grew up in an orphanage in
Russia.
I lived there for 12 years and then I came
to the United States.
And I've been working countless hours at sorry,
at the elephant bank and in the skid row.
And I just think it's so insulting.
There is some saying, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to cry.
Speaker 4: It's okay.
Just talk through the tears.
I want to hear what.
Speaker 1: Dr. Phil's like.
Please.
No, cry more.
Keep talking as you cry.
It's good for the ratings.
Do you have.
Speaker 4: To say.
Speaker 3: I'm someone who came from Russia
and have been putting in countless hours working,
volunteering for people in Skid Row?
Speaker 2: What would you do?
Speaker 3: Real simple to you that we are
not the worst people in the world.
Our overall.
Speaker 4: 31, right.
I've been mentoring young guys since I was
18 from the ages.
Speaker 2: Of 14 through 24.
Yeah, I grew up in an inner city of Detroit.
Speaker 1: There's this weird thing about
the Dr. Phil Show where so we know Jesse Lee
Peterson is completely vile.
I don't know that we need too much of a commentary
on that.
There is this weird vibe on the Dr. Phil Show
where it's sort of like they try to present
it like a serious show, but it kind of has
like Jerry Springer, Maury Povich vibes.
And I don't know, it's it's like every detail,
something about the way it's filmed, something
about the lighting and the color temperature,
the lower thirds and the font even.
I can't exactly put my finger on what it is,
but it just feels like one of those types
of shows, even though it kind of seems like
they're taking themselves seriously.
Bizarre stuff.
I don't even know how much Dr. Phil's people
knew about Jesse Lee Peterson when they had
him on, but quite literally, saying things
so disgusting, they make members of the audience
cry strange and bizarre stuff.